a leak on Moya is German Moroccan he's
lived in the town of Karin for more than
20 years sometimes he runs into friends
at the newsstand there's always someone
here to talk to people exchange
pleasantries and chat about events of
the day they also talk about Karen's
integration projects for Refugees
something Ali Kawa is actively involved
with work well together here in Canton
and live peacefully with one another in
terms of integration we've been very
successful more than 70 thousand people
live in Kampen a tenth of them moved
here from other countries many as guest
workers who found jobs in coal mines or
the auto industry the small industrial
city west of Cologne has become their
home they're proud of their city and
feel a part of it but what happened in
Cologne on New Year's Eve came as a
shock to many hundreds of women were
sexually assaulted and robbed
preliminary arrests were made in Karen's
refugee camp two Algerians were accused
of possessing stolen cellphones one of
them allegedly took part in the attacks
on women someone who knows the two young
men expressed surprise at the
accusations
I don't believe they took part in the
sexual harassment to be honest it is
true that they do steal but I just don't
believe the other accusation
the rated karpin's refugee shelter the
arrests and the seizure of stolen goods
many of the people living here were
taken aback for its icon and all people
of countries the control you understand
control you see give me your advice
after he catch this to a person in this
room of these guys he take witness
reports claimed that most of the
perpetrators were from northern Africa
all of them young men who came to
Germany alone
Zachary Amer one did as well but the
young Moroccan doesn't want to be lumped
together with criminals they shouldn't
do things like that because all of us
whether we're from Morocco Algeria
Tunisia or Asia were all people and just
want to live and work in Germany Zakaria
is attending a vocational school to
prepare for an apprenticeship
he works hard and wants to make the most
of his opportunity his instructor Jeremy
Jason is worried that the attacks in
Cologne will make it harder for young
male refugees to be accepted this
blanket suspicion is very hurtful to
these people who make the effort every
day to do their work and then when
they're on a bus or something like that
they're met with hostility that they
don't deserve the offenders in Cologne
have done damage to the reputation of
all immigrants Zakaria and his friends
won't stand for that they want to help
restore the honour of North Africans in
Germany